PRIYANKA VERGADIA:
Hey, Pat, what's up?
PAT: Priyanka, I'm in
crisis mode right now.
My boss has asked me
to migrate to cloud,
and I don't know what to do.
PRIYANKA VERGADIA: OK,
slow down and don't worry.
In the next few minutes, we
will lay out the five easy steps
to kickstart your Google
Cloud migration journey.
PAT: Wow, that would be awesome.
Thanks so much.
PRIYANKA VERGADIA: OK, Pat,
hang on the line, and you all,
stay tuned.
[MUSIC PLAYING]
Hi, everyone.
I'm Priyanka, and welcome
to Cloud Migration 101,
where we will talk about
all things migration.
In this first
episode, I'll show you
how to get started with
your migration journey
to Google Cloud.
What is cloud migration anyway?
Well, it typically refers
to moving apps deployed
on premises into
the cloud, maybe
to leverage the benefits
of cloud like reduced cost,
increased security,
flexibility, and speed.
It could also mean
moving workloads
from one cloud to another.
Any type of moving
can be a challenge.
Putting things into right
boxes, what if something gets
lost or breaks, can you
put it all back together?
Well, cloud migration
is no different, even
for the most experienced teams.
So you need to plan and execute
your migration very carefully.
Where do we get started?
Well, the first stop in
the migration journey
to Google Cloud town is to
define your starting point.
Now, starting point
could be on premises
where you manage the entire
infrastructure and the apps.
It could be in private
hosting environment,
where you manage the
virtualization and resources,
and the rest is managed
by the service provider.
Or it could be in another cloud.
Now that we have defined the
starting and the end points,
we are ready to jump in to
stop number two, the types
of workloads to migrate.
This is important
because it helps
us assess the complexity
of the migration.
There can be different
kinds of workloads.
But for our purposes
today, it is
safe to categorize them
as legacy workloads
and cloud native workloads.
Legacy workloads are developed
without any consideration
for cloud environment.
So it can be difficult and
frankly expensive to modify
them to run on cloud.
On the other hand,
cloud-native workloads
are natively scalable,
portable, available, and secure.
So consider the type of workload
you're dealing with while
planning a migration.
Now, we are at stop three.
It's time to pick the type of
migration that makes sense.
There's lift and shift,
where you move workloads
from a source to a
target environment
with minor or no modifications.
This is ideal when a
workload can operate
as is in the target environment,
or when there's little
or no business need for change.
It also requires the
least amount of time
and are easiest to accomplish.
The disadvantages-- you have
a non-cloud-native workload
running in Google
Cloud now, which is not
ideal to take full
advantage of Cloud Platform
features like horizontal
scaling, pricing,
and managed services.
The second type of migration
is improve and move,
in which you modernize the
workload while migrating
it to take advantage of
cloud native capabilities.
This may take longer than the
lift and shift, because you're
refactoring, but it turns out
to be better in the long run,
because you gain access to many
of the cloud-native benefits.
The third type is
rip and replace
migration, where you
decommission an existing app
and completely
redesign and rewrite it
as a cloud-native app.
You would do this if your
current app is too expensive
to migrate, or you don't
want to maintain it.
This will obviously
take a lot longer,
but the upside is this
migration sets you up
to take full advantage of
those amazing cloud features,
including the horizontal
scaling, managed services,
and high availability.
Once you decide which
migration type makes
sense for your
business workload,
we move one to the fourth stop
on our migration journey--
assess your readiness for cloud.
Your readiness depends
on four themes--
learning programs,
leadership support,
experience to scale cloud-native
services, and the capacity
to protect your
current environment.
For each theme, you should be
in one of the three phases--
tactical, strategic,
or transformational.
Since this is an exercise
that highly depends
on your organization's
maturity for adopting cloud
technologies,
click here to learn
how to evaluate your
organization on the cloud
maturity scale.
Stop five on our
journey is to define
the core of the migration,
the migration path.
It has four phases.
You assess, you plan, you
deploy, and then you optimize.
Got it?
No.
Let me try that again
a little bit slower.
In the assess phase, you
perform a thorough assessment
and discovery of your
existing environment
to understand your
app inventory,
identify any dependencies
and requirements,
perform total cost of
ownership calculations,
and establish app
performance benchmarks.
In the plan phase, you create
the basic cloud infrastructure
for your apps and plan
how you will move them.
This planning includes creating
an organization, folders,
environments,
projects, resources,
and networks, along with access
controls, sorting the apps,
and developing a prioritized
migration strategy.
In deploy phase, you
design, implement,
and execute deployment
processes to move workloads
to Google Cloud.
And in the optimize
phase, you'll
begin to take full advantage
of cloud-native technology,
such as performance,
scalability, disaster recovery,
cost, training, as well as
opening the doors to machine
learning and
artificial intelligence
integrations for your apps.
Here's the summary
of five steps we
defined to kickstart
your migration
journey to Google Cloud.
First, you define the
starting point and end
point, which is Google Cloud.
Then you define your
workloads followed
by the migration types.
Then using the cloud
adoption framework,
assess your readiness
for your cloud journey.
And finally, get set
for the migration path,
assess, plan,
deploy, and optimize.
Now that we have
a starting point,
Pat is off building their
migration plan to Google Cloud.
You all, stay tuned for the next
episode, where we will help you
choose what to migrate first.
If you've got thoughts on
different methods you've used,
leave a comment below so we
can continue our conversation.
Until then, like,
subscribe, to keep
learning about cloud migration.
Oh, and check out the more
detailed Getting Started Guide
by our solutions architect,
Mark [INAUDIBLE]..